oder wird sehen wir dich vielleicht
mitunter deutschland herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video von mir
cool freut mich ja videos hoch und
dustin hoffman videos ist in der tat wir
haben uns heute hier versammelt kann man
mit und hoffmann die wogen haben uns
hier heute versammeln bei der damen und
herren weil ich mal wieder auch
instagram unterwegs war so heißt sich
auf instagram ihr könnt mir da gern
folge sind auch ein wechsel zwei
millionen ich habe einige andere ist
account ausgecheckt habe mir ein paar
bilder ausgesucht irgendwie ich dann
heute in dem video mit dem titel auch
schon stark machen werde
wow nach stellen werde richtig coole ja
weil sie schafft das
danke sachen gelang gar nicht lang
das erste bild
das erste bild meine damen und herren
ihr seht schon eingeblendet ferrara das
heißt ich werde mich jetzt noch ein
bisschen so zu setzen ist das die
richtige seite wenn das so oder andere
seite
so müssen raus geschickt dass andere ein
bisschen angewinkelt auf dem was ich
angerichtet und einen muss das jetzt
allerdings tut mir das vor
ob es hat finanztest zu vertagen da darf
man den zweiten rang freuen ist denn ich
wundervoll wo gibt es denn zu kaufen
also dafür ein habe ich angewinkelt das
heißt die eine hand so mit den fingern
muss nicht so ein bisschen das an die
andra hantierte drauf und jetzt wird es
ein bisschen so gut das kann man das
einloggen
du bist so ein super kamerafrau
wir sehen bereits das nächste bild
eingeblendet meine damen und herren es
ist er steht dort ein bankenvertreter
gegangen so eine band habe gehe ich
natürlich erst mal so ein bisschen
runter auf deine niveau juli obwohl sie
da kann ich gar nicht gibt so ein
bisschen so und die kamera sollte man
hat hier die arme und hier das ganze ja
verstehen wir sind gerade auf der suche
nach gold ist die vorfreude das gleiche
geld erst mal ganz kurz im keller genau
also das hier ist die nächste position
vor film studios erhalten das ist besten
fertig wenn nicht in der das ist auf
jeden fall die nächste position werde
daher sein quote von sascha können ich
bin nicht in der mitte ich muss auf
jeden fall ganzkörper drauf das heißt
wir müssen nach hinten müssen wir auf
dem boden
beide hände in den hosentaschen steht
ein bisschen seitliche jacke an moment
ist er doch einige schuhe also wird es
kein boxen schon mehr wohnungen zu gehen
dass er steht so ein bisschen seitlich
und so ein bisschen krumm und puppen die
kamera ich vielleicht mitunter
bis nächste bild müssen wir uns bewegen
und zwar das bild dieses hiervon dank
bei der damen und herren ich bin doch
nicht mit ihm gemacht auf diesem bild
gerade werbung für einen rasierer elan
und was hat das heißt die vom ein
rasierer und dieses ist immer im weg ich
nehme jetzt einfach mal irgendwas was
ich je gesehen habe da noch meinen
rasierer du musstest ein bisschen weiter
runter da wir einmal an dem linken das
andere bein hat die vielleicht
ausgestreckt und dabei sieht sie sich
gerade dann hier mit modernen zeigte das
produkt und hiermit rasiert sie sich und
macht dann kann man ja dass man freunde
oder das nenne ich einen satz hier meine
fresse und was ist das eigentlich ein
schönes wetter de
das ist das nächste bild meine damen und
herren und zwar von meinem werten
kollegen marcel der die tage geburtstag
an der stelle noch mal keine schöne
grüße an
das foto ist seitlich so vermissen das
handy du musst dich auf jeden fall daten
stellen ich lebe ich hier so ein
bisschen auf moment wenn partikeln den
später mensch ist das für den captain
hat auf jeden fall last fallen hier so
ein bisschen an gebiet wird und die
freude angehen dann bleibt natürlich
nach hinten auf und selbst der
sonnenbrille auf dasselbe was ist für
sein alter meine stadt solle jetzt
leider verloren gegangen deswegen muss
ich jetzt hin und wieder aufsetzen
lassen wir hier wieder so dann setze ich
die helligkeit schon allein um jetzt
gerade jetzt noch auf die hände in den
taschen ein bisschen so und wir dürfen
ja solche das ist ein bisschen rund oder
was trägst du erster tutorial
ich brauche dich fürs nächste bild
bedacht wird braucht es jetzt gute
freunde das wenigste jeden mit seiner
mutter ein ich muss nicht so ein arm
nehmen und mussten uns über das handy
sollte dass der mann zwar schön bei der
dramatischen situation die nur gucken
ich muss ein bisschen dankbar
das nächste bild ist von timo 21 11 ich
weiß nicht erhält mit der rechten hand
die kamera mit der linken hand macht
irgendwie so zeigt ebenso drei teile hat
das hier so andere machte warum kommt
man so ein foto hoch wir brauchen ein
paar freunde allerdings bevor wir das
machen uns eigentlich mal ganz kurz
trägt mit bürsten mit dem fast wenn man
dem team bei dem ich so mache einfach so
und dann hat man sowas tun gemacht mit
aber auch noch eine andere welt macht
nämlich so sodano balczuweit halt
normalerweise auch nicht weg da gibt es
noch andere formen ist unser spiel so
und dann macht man einfach so und haben
heute war eigentlich auch nicht weg man
hat mich auch cristiano das nächste bild
ist auf jeden fall von daybreak
er hat den ball in der rechten hand so
den dienst runter und ach ja richtig
machen gerade
kauft alle meine freunde dass hier
wirklich eine wunderschöne lektüre
zusammen mit meiner mutter geschrieben
über mich und mein ganzes leben sagt er
selbst lange dran sind viele private
informationen rechnet amazon link und in
der beschreibung wurde davon das
weihnachtsgeschenk auch für jung und alt
europa sich noch was wünscht ihr das
bewegte bild ist von einer und zwar ist
hier so ein bisschen nach dem vorbild
schaut euch noch einen koffer und hier
eine schule in diesem strang ziehen
kommentiert das heißt auch so gut hass
teil gerade eine ist offen
anzug schuhe wieder so ein bisschen so
ich geh jetz auch noch zeit
betroffene diabetiker wird damit die mir
hei
wer das nächste bild ist vorfreude
darauf düsseldorf du müsstest du auf
jeden fall nicht mal ganz groß auf den
spieler
jawohl laut schild auf dem foto hier mit
ihren besten freundinnen deswegen würde
ich sagen ich damals meinen freunden
hier
sie haben auf jeden fall dass eine
beiden so ein bisschen so dass andere
ein bisschen hinten schaut ihren
freunden auf jeden fall laufen die augen
macht es doppelt tief und sogar das
angeschaut zu gemüte geführt einige
bilder herausgesucht die ich jetzt nach
gemacht habe der beste in spammer ist
trotzdem immer noch der hier und da
sollte man auf jeden fall mal einfallen
lassen denn bei euch dieses video hier
gefallen hat und ihr habt doch darauf
dass ich öfter irgendwie sowas mache
oder das ist mir vielleicht sogar die
ersten instagram bilder von einigen
youtube anschauen schreiben es auf jeden
fall mal die kommentare last allem
unlike da ja dass meine lampe und jetzt
kommt das auto das was ihr vom video das
was jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinem haus
schenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen